I'm Mike Beals and I'm an assistant scout master with Troop 226 in Roswell, Georgia.
This edition of the Scout Master podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scout Master,
As a scouter, it's a good thing to know the technical definitions of things in nature:
An acorn, the definition of an acorn, that would be a good thing to know.
Share with your scouts.
I can tell you in a nutshell: it's an oak tree in it.
Oh man,
Thanks or blame.
Go to Shane Adams for that one.
Hey, this is podcast number 309..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's not waste any time and look straight into the mailbag.
Joshua Jones left us a nice review of my book, The Scouting Journey, on Amazon.
It's a well-written and insightful book about scouting.
Definitely a good tool to have in a Scout Master's toolbag.
Thanks, Joshua.
Eric Fletcher is with Troop 309 in Pepperpike, Orange Village, Ohio,
And he wrote to say I hope podcast number 309 is not in the can yet.
Well, it is now. but you made it, Eric.
Troop 309, podcast 309, everybody get it.
Okay.
But Eric went on to say I started my Scout Master CG apprenticeship about a year ago
when there were rumors I was next in line for Scout Master.
Now, I never saw a line, but I'd taken the Scout Master Assistant,
Scout Master Leader training at our council to find that our Troop said
we don't exactly do it that way.
Realizing I didn't know what I was doing, I started searching for information and found your site.
I worked my way through all of your podcast, finishing before winter break.
My view and approach of scouting has changed since my first podcast.
Many times I've started planning a course of action only to listen to the next podcast,
And here I probably should do it a bit differently.
You're like the conscience who stands on a Scout Master's shoulder and whispers in his ear.
That would take a very large shoulder indeed, Eric.
But no, I appreciate the kind words
And I'm glad we can be helpful to you.
Hey, every week we try and get together with listeners and readers at scoutmastercgcom
for a live chat session.
Usually we manage to have two of those a week,
True to form. we had the couple of chat sessions this past week.
Usually we have them on Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
Keep an eye on our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed
and you'll see an announcement when we're live at scoutmastercgcom.
Come on in. sign in to the chat,
Like many of our frequent flyers do,
And also for their first time on the chat. this week.
we had Craig Snodgrass, who's the Scout Master Troop one and now the Dean of California,
Brad Chilcoat, who's the Scout Master Troop 59 in Little Rock, Arkansas,
And Jennifer Garner, who is an American ex-patriot living in the Commonwealth of Dominica,
interested in starting a BSA Scout Troop down there in Dominica.
So it's good to hear from everybody once again.
Usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings,
Look at our Facebook feed and our Twitter feed
and come and join us on the live chat.
Hey, if you're a regular reader and listener and what we're doing is helping you,
you can return the favor and help us.
You can support the podcast by making a one-time payment and becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer,
Or you can make a subscription payment through Patreon by pledging $5 or more a month.
Now there are special premiums available to anyone who becomes a patron or a backer.
To become a backer, go to scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link at the top of the page.
You'll find a number of options that'll make you a scoutmastercgcom backer.
And this week I want to take a moment to personally thank Jim Jenser, Lois Holler,
Michael Lyons and Eric Fletcher, who've all become backers since our last podcast,
And to become a patron, click the link to my Patreon page and the podcast notes,
or just go directly to wwwpatreon and that's p-a-t-r-e-o-ncom backslash scoutmastercg.
So take advantage of either methods of lending us a hand
and I'll make sure to thank you personally on next week's podcast.
Now the remainder of this podcast is going to be taken up with the second in my three-part series
about scout parents, And last week we asked ourselves whether or not parents should make
their children stay in scouts. So go back and listen to podcast number 308 if you haven't heard
that, And this week I'm going to tell you what I wish every scout parent understood,
And that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast. so let's get started, shall we?
So? in the second of a series about scout parents, I'm going to give a shot at discussing one of the
thornier issues that parents and scouts find themselves in the middle of,
And that is letting their scouts or their children learn things through the scouting process.
Now, this is not a new problem. It is not something that started happening five or ten
or twenty or thirty years ago. It's always been there ever since we started doing scouts.
I think there is a gap of understanding between parents and scouters about exactly how the process
is intended to work. Now I want to make sure you understand what I'm saying here,
because I think it's really important. Scout parents have always misunderstood scouting.
Scouters have always misunderstood scouting. in one way or another,
We all are working towards the idea of getting to know it better.
It takes time and effort to learn the process and what it's all about.
I want to remind you it's not always a parent problem. A lot of times it's a
scouter problem. I think one of the bigger mistakes we make as scouters and as human beings
is, once we've reached a certain age, we sit back and complain about kids these days- quote
unquote- or parents these days- quote unquote. Listen, if you want to complain about how
things were different than they were when you were a kid, I'm really not interested in listening.
I think really, let's just quit our whining and get over ourselves and make progress for our scouts
as they come to us now. Otherwise, just let's get out of the way and let somebody else have
a try. Am I clear enough? Am I clear enough about that? I mean, I'm not trying to be offensive,
I'm just trying to say I think it's a big waste of time and it's just plain frustrating
to say I wish these scouts would come to me understanding what I understood when I was a
kid. Stop it, Okay, let's just deal with them as they come to us now and do some good
Now. parents have a very important role in scouting and I want to give you the most important
information a scout parent needs to know and what I wish every scout parent and scouter
understood. and helping parents understand what we're trying to accomplish in scouting
and how we accomplish it has always been one of my key challenges as a scouter. A lot of times when
I try to explain the scouting process, parents think they know what I'm talking about, but they
really don't. Scouts think they know what I'm talking about, but they really don't, because
what we have to do is leave all of our assumptions at the door and understand that
scouting is unique. It's different from school and church and sports and any other youth
organizations. Now I will say that some organizations are looking a lot more like scouting because they
have adopted some of the ideas that scouting was founded on, but the process of scouting is a unique
one and one that takes some study and dedication to begin to understand and help other people
understand. Scouting is not simply another activity on the schedule. it is a process
and once parents understand the process, they'll become your allies. until they do, we can find
ourselves working at cross purposes with the parents of our scouts. What we have to understand
in scouting, there are at least two things happening at once most of the time. There's the immediate
practical goal, like getting a merit badge or going camping or something like that, and the
much broader and more important goal of developing character and citizenship and
physical and spiritual and mental fitness. The scouting process is really very similar to
the parenting process. It may look a little harsh at times or it may make a scout parent feel
they're not being responsible, and that's an uncomfortable feeling for most of us. but being
uncomfortable, that's not a bad thing, because scouting is not only an opportunity for young
people to grow, it's just. it's an opportunity for scouters and parents to grow as well.
To be a good scout parent or a good scouter, you have to be open and available to that
process that you're going to learn things. Now I've mentioned the scouting process a number
of times, but let me explain exactly what I'm talking about because, very simply put,
scouting is something that young people do for themselves. it is not something that they have
done for them. Now, that might at first seem a little oversimplified, but it's something that's
easy to remember. Scouting is something that young people do for themselves. it is not something
that is done for their benefit or presented to them, And while it's very simple to say
it is infinitely, it can be infinitely complex to come to an understanding of that's what this
whole process is actually about. My stepson works for the college he attended and he works with
students there, and one of the things that he will tell you is that one key skill many new
students lack is the ability to navigate very routine things for themselves, things that they
are used to having done for them, And I'm talking like from laundry to signing up for classes and
managing a schedule. and he will also tell you that the way he learned to do things for himself,
he largely attributes to his participation in scouting. So what I really wish that scout
parents understood in a large part is something that you really can't understand until you've
been through, until you've been through this process, When you're the parent of an 11 year old
and you've never been a parent before, you think that you pretty much know what the next few years
are going to be like and what the result of those years is going to be, until you actually go through
parenting a child, through those years, and once you've done that, well, then you sit back and
you go. wow, I really did not have much understanding about this at all, and that's true with most
things in life, isn't it? I mean, we really don't understand the processes of life until we have
gone through them and we're on the other side of them. So we're all learning as we go along.
parents are learning, young people in scouting are learning, and scouters are learning, and
we're learning new things every single day. even though I've watched hundreds of scouts and families
and hundreds of sets of parents go through this process, I still learn new things about it. so,
beyond understanding that scouting is something that young people do for themselves- it's not
something that is done for them and presented to them. it's something that they do for themselves-
the other thing to understand as a scouting parent and a scouter, is that we need to be open
and available for the fact that we are going to learn things as we move along that we don't know
everything, which is a lot easier said than done, isn't it? I know it. I know it is, in my case at least.
so what does this process look like in practical terms? well, when a scout goes camping, he needs
to find out what to bring, gather all that stuff together and put it in a pack and bring it with
him. I mean, it's perfectly understandable that a parent of a younger scout or even an older scout
may feel they need to do some or all of this for their scout. that's understandable. you want to be
a responsible parent. you don't want your child to suffer needlessly. so if there's a list of
things that they're supposed to bring, you're going to look at the list and make sure they bring
it right. and there's also this other idea that if your child doesn't arrive fully prepared for
a camping trip, that that's going to reflect poorly upon you as a parent. I mean, what were you thinking?
now, trust me, if it was true, that every parent of a child who arrived without some key
piece of equipment for a camping trip was a bad parent, that means all parents are bad.
I mean, after you know 35 or 40 years of going camping, I still forget stuff. so whenever a scout
packs their own bag, they are likely to forget something, and they may, and the fact that they
forgot it may make them a little uncomfortable while they're out camping. now remember, we're there,
scouters are there and we're not going to allow them to endanger themselves because they've
forgotten something. they may suffer a little bit and they may suffer a little bit existentially,
but we're going to make sure they're physically safe. so it's a safe environment for them to forget
and to learn from forgetting, which is a part of the process. a story I want to share with you also
points out another practical part of this. it was several years back. boy goes to summer camp
for his first year supposed to do swimming maripage. doesn't come home with swimming maripage
completed. now, this is not a big giant deal. it is when you're 11 and all of your other friends
get their maripage. it can be a little tragic, but in the grand scheme of things, the fact that this
happened presents us with some teachable moments and some opportunities. so naturally, the scout
who did not get swimming maripage finished while he was at camp was disappointed, but his parents, and
specifically his father, was even more upset that somehow he came home without this maripage. now
we discussed the whole thing with the parent in excruciating detail. I mean the number of times
we reminded his son that he had to go to the pool and the fact that his son simply didn't.
he found allowing an 11 year old that kind of latitude in making a decision like that
was unacceptable to him. it was our responsibility to force the boy to do something and, as I remember
it, you know, in the way of 11 year old, we talked to the boy, told him he had to get to the pool,
finish up swimming maripage. he assured us he would then turned out by the end of the week that
he hadn't. and we did exactly what we've done hundreds and hundreds of times before and
somehow the other scouts that were in the same situation came back with swimming maripage, but
this scout didn't. it was not an irreconcilable failure. it was not shaming or belittling for the boy,
it was not in the least bit negative until his parent decided that it was. and we talked about
how the scout could finish up the last few requirements and the possibilities that the
scouting process had created for dad to discuss decision making and responsibility and consequences
with his son and how, what he learns from the process is one step closer to the broader goal
of scouting. but he really wouldn't have any of that and that was the last time we saw that boy in
scouts. now that's an extreme example of a parent not buying into the process with us, not being
able to cooperate with us, because part of the scouting process is the inevitability of a scout
failing or coming up short or making the wrong decision about something. we're there to keep
them physically safe and mentally stable and not to shame them or belittle them for
making poor decisions, but to let those poor decisions create an opportunity for the process
of scouting to happen, where they can examine what they've done and think about it and use the
experience as a teachable moment. but sometimes parents feel that that is overly harsh or overly
permissive and they just can't get on board with it. but if you do get on board and you cooperate
with that process, if you keep your eye on the broader goal, you'll see your scout start to grow
and figure things out for themselves. you'll find that your job is not so much telling your child
to do things or doing for your child, but is helping them discover answers how they can do things
for themselves. your job is not making things easier, but helping your child look past the
initial frustrations and learn to ask questions of themselves and to grow in confidence and ability.
and they always surprise you when that happens. I mean really, you know, it just seems to be this
incredible miracle when this happens. but if you value the process and you stick with it and you
make a commitment to do it, it always results in very positive things. now, as parents and as
scouts, it can be a very uncomfortable thing. it is not easy watching young people figure out
how to do things for themselves. we get uncomfortable, our scouts get frustrated, and when scouts get
frustrated, sometimes what happens is their parents go after the scouts for not doing enough or
allowing things to be chaotic, inefficient or needlessly difficult. but the scouting process
is purposefully designed to be challenging and every scout and scout parent is going to experience
frustration or discouragement from time to time. we embrace those challenges. frustration and discouragement
are good because we can turn them to our advantage to help our scouts achieve the broader goals
of scouting. so when our scouts are going through this whole process and they get discouraged or
frustrated, that's when we need a supportive, responsible parent to step up and to help them
overcome the discouragement or the frustration and to keep on trying. scouting cooperates with parents
who cooperate with scouting. it's an interdependent relationship. it gives parents powerful opportunities
to help their children grow. what we do in scouting is almost never about the immediate practical
goal. it's always about the broader goals and that one way of keeping those goals in view is
to understand that scouting is not something that we prepare and do and present to young people.
it is a process in which young people learn to do for themselves. every scouter and scout parent
ought to understand that. but i'm not frustrated by the fact that initially you don't, because
learning how the scouting process works and learning how to cooperate with it is actually
part of the process for parents and scouts to participate in with their children.
and when you do, it's very, very satisfied. and when you do learn to cooperate with that process,
amazing things happen, not just for your children but for you as well.
thank you so much for listening to this 309th edition of the scout master podcast. here's how
to keep in touch. you can go and read our blog at scoutmastercgcom. there's about 1600 different
articles about being a scouter there, plus there's a 309 podcast to listen to as of this week and you
can subscribe to receive updates to the blog and email at scoutmastercgcom. we're all over social
media too and a lot of folks follow us that way. there are 12 000 folks who like scout master
blog on facebook, we have 1300 and some tweeters on twitter. 2500 people pin the
paltritudinous pictures we proffer publicly on pinterest. we've got some videos over at youtube
and so forth and so forth. but listen, if none of that works for you, if you don't put the you in
youtube and you can't face facebook and twitter makes you better and you've just no interest
in pinterest, that's all right. bunkie, zoom into the late 1990s and fire off a good old-fashioned
email. i'm always available at clark at scoutmastercgcom. c, l, a, r, k, e at scoutmastercgcom. now, if none of
that works for you, the next time you're standing around a campfire with your fellow scouters,
take a magic mirror, look into it and say scout mastercg three times, not four times, not five,
not two, but three times, and i will appear to answer all of your questions. well, by now
it must be abundantly clear that the scout master blog and the scout master podcast are not official
publications of anybody in particular other than myself. we are not, uh, sponsored or endorsed by the
boy scouts of america, or any other scouting organization for that matter. it's just me talking
into a microphone, trying to lend a hand to my fellow scouters and have a little bit of fun along
the way. and speaking of fun, here he is our founder, sir robert baton. pal, sir robert,
good luck to you and good camping, why? thank you, sir, until next time, everyone.